this is candy it's called candy because
it was originally from India where
sugarcane was first processed into sugar
crystals and around the 4th century AD
with a piece of sugar referred to as
Kanda in sanskrit now as the knowledge
of the cultivation and processing of
sugar spread westwards into what was
then Persia sometime in the 6th century
the word used to refer to the process of
coating something in sugar syrup became
undie in arabic and then as that
knowledge made its way westwards to
europe eventually we get the english
word candy sometime in the 13th century
etymology or the study of the origin of
words can reveal a story how we got to
an object or an ideas importance in the
world where it came from but unlike
candy sine and cos as words don't really
mean anything and their story tells us
why to go back to the beginning the
concept of sine originates in India in
the Gupta period and the 4th or 5th
century AD previously ancient Greek
mathematicians had considered the
relationship between the length of a
chord that's any line that connects two
points on the perimeter of a circle and
the angle subtended at the center of the
circle by back court but the writers of
the sedan toss one of the most important
texts in ancient Indian mats instead
considered the relationship between half
the length of a chord and half the angle
subtended at the center and this is
directly related to the modern concept
of sine if a circle has radius one then
it's half chord has length sine X if X
is half the angle subtended at the
center in sanskrit which was the
liturgical language of India at that
time the chord is referred to as Gia
meaning bowstring it's kind of obvious
to see why the chord looks like a
bowstring if the rest of the circle
forms the bow and a common synonym of
Gia at the time was Jeeva which is the
word that ended up sticking to refer to
both the chord and the idea we now know
as sine mathematicians working in Gupta
era India defines two huge concepts that
we use all the time in maths today
sign as we've already seen and literally
how we write numbers around the same
time that sign was invented modern
decimal notation was also invented where
each column of a number is 10 times
larger than the previous column not
replaced earlier systems which are a bit
more unwieldy like sexagesimal where
each column was 60 times larger than the
previous one it's no exaggeration to say
that mathematicians working in Gupta era
India redefined a lot of how we
currently think about maths but those
ideas had to get from India to Europe
where it was eventually standardized
into the notation that we use today and
the journey it took to get there is
where we get the names sine and cos
exactly as with candy as the idea of
sine spread from India to what was then
Persia the word used to refer to it was
transliterated from sanskrit into arabic
because there was no direct equivalent
that already existed so Jeeva became
giba now this next bit is important
because something's about to go wrong
because in arabic words can be
abbreviated by omitting short vowels and
as such for convenience when written
down giba became jib but this only works
if you know what the abbreviation was in
full in the first place because there
could be any short vowels between the
remaining consonants normally of course
that's not a problem if you speak Arabic
and you're familiar with the conventions
you can substitute in the original
vowels but when Western Europeans
started translating our of mathematical
documents in the 12th century
what would the increased contact between
the two cultures there was a problem
Europe hadn't been thinking much about
maths for the past well nearly thousand
years instead focusing on salvation and
who the successors the Roman Empire was
so when they gained access to Arabic
texts which brilliantly extended the
works of ancient Greek and Indian
mathematicians and scientists they began
fervently translating them and they
translated them into medieval Latin
which was the language of maths at the
time a translator and it's not
universally agreed on who this was but
it was probably Robert of Chester who
incidentally was the first person to
translate the Koran into Latin or Gerard
of Cremona
got their hands on a book in Arabic
called the compendium of calculation by
completion and balancing and within this
book were tables of the values of the
sine of an angle referred to as jib but
the translator whoever it was didn't
realize that that was short for giba and
instead interpreted it as being short
for Jeb the Arabic word for bosom or
pouch
therefore he translated Jim in Arabic
into sinus in Latin which is the word
meaning bosom or fold or cavity
incidentally why your sinuses in your
head are called that they're literally
air cavities in your skull and this name
stuck in Latin which remained the
language of maths for centuries right up
until mathematicians and in particular
boiler standardized notation sign being
short for sinus and cos for
trigonometric functions cusp
incidentally is short for cosine or more
completely in Latin complimenti sinus
meaning the thing which varies with sine
but the word we use today sine was an
English corruption of the Latin word
sinus so as a word it only has a
mathematical meaning it simply didn't
exist until English mathematicians
started using the Latin function sinus
sometime in the 16th century so perhaps
it's fitting them that after centuries
of history and a dodgy translation into
Latin that the first person recorded to
use the word sine in English was called
Thomas fail so the next time that you're
stuck in a trigonometry test and you're
staring blankly at the questions take
some comfort in the fact that the person
who named sine and cos didn't really
know what they were doing either if you
want to prepare for that test though
then the best way you can do so is to
actively engage with some problems that
develop your mathematical toolkit and
give you a deep understanding of the
concepts at hand and the best way to do
that is through brilliant org a website
that promotes learning through problem
solving time and time again I get asked
what's the best way to get better at
math
and my answer is the same every single
time practice practice practice the more
problems you do the better you will get
and bRILINTA org is a great place to do
that as even if you do get a question
wrong it will correct you and remind you
it's okay
getting stumped is part of learning in
particular their courses on mathematical
fundamentals and algebra flu puzzles are
a great place for you to get started and
get stumped if you'd like to try Brillon
for free then go to related org forward
slash Simon Clark were the first 200
people to go to that link we'll also get
20% off their annual premium
subscription and it helps me grow this
channel thank you for watching if you
enjoyed the video please do pop it alike
if you're not already subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time
[Music]